[Music]
hey everyone
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 20
of you are subscribed we'd love to hit
250 000
before the end of the year so if you
enjoyed the regular content
be sure to hit that subscribe button
welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory for today's video
we're going to be discussing a theory
that i can't take credit for creating
it's a theory that has been floating
around the internet for years
a theory that directly affects harry
potter's character
and threatens the very existence of the
entire wizarding world
i am of course talking about the theory
that hogwarts
witches wizards magic wands
and broomsticks are purely a figment of
harry's imagination
this theory is based around the idea
that harry
an abused and downtrodden young boy had
to imagine and create his own reality
a world that he could escape to when his
own world became too much to handle
if we go by this theory the only real
aspects
of the harry potter universe are a that
harry lives with the dursleys
and b that harry's parents are in fact
dead
however if the magical world never
actually existed
then it would of course mean that
harry's parents weren't killed
by the powerful lord voldemort they
really did just die
in a car crash as the dursleys always
told him
one thing is for certain in both
realities
the dursleys are awful to harry and
according to the theory
it's their abusive nature that pushes
him to the point of creating his own
imaginary world in the harry potter
books and films
harry is only left with the dursleys
because by staying with them
it meant that he was safe from voldemort
the result of lily's loving sacrifice
the only logical explanation for harry
staying with them
in this other circumstance is that harry
simply didn't have
at the family he had nowhere else to go
orphaned by a horrible car crash that
claimed the lives of both of his parents
harry was forced to go and live with
aunt petunia and uncle vernon
oh and we can't forget the awful dudley
the dursleys were truly awful to harry
and i have no doubt in my mind that
their abuse could push a young man
who had already lost his parents to the
point of well
insanity to the point of creating his
own reality
the following passage from the book
confirms that a
harry had no other family and b he
dreamed and dreamed of his life changing
for the better
when he had been younger harry had
dreamed and dreamed
of some unknown relation coming to take
him away
but it had never happened the dursleys
were his only family
over the course of the books films the
dursleys
particularly vernon dussley did a lot of
horrible things to harry
including but not limited to putting
bars and harry's window in the chamber
of secrets
shutting harry's owl hedwig in a locked
cage in order to prevent harry
from having any source of happiness
while at privet drive
keeping harry from reading his mail and
forcing harry to live
in a cupboard under the stairs while all
of these are awful
with some more cruel than the others
it's important to remember that if the
magical world
never existed then hedwig his hogwarts
letters
and the necessity to place bars on
harry's windows would have never existed
the only thing that would remain is
perhaps the cruelest aspect
of his existence at number four privet
drive and that
is his tiny bedroom under the stairs a
world without magic would also
mean that the dursleys never hated harry
potter for his associations with magic
it would just mean that they were truly
awful people it would also mean that
petunia hated her sister lily
for other reasons altogether or maybe
she never hated lily at all
she was only bitter and awful to harry
because she was resentful of the fact
that she was stuck
raising another person's child when
harry turned 11 years old
his entire world changed and his
adventures at hogwarts began
a wonderful period of his life that
finally provided him
with the long-awaited escape from the
reality
that he so hated however a grim thought
is that
if harry never left that cupboard under
the stairs if he never left number four
private drive
it may have just meant that his 11th
birthday was the beginning
of the deterioration of harry's mental
health
it was a point at which he had suffered
so much that he could endure
his own reality no more the same way
that an obscurus
is manifested inside of a child after
years of abuse
harry's harsh reality manifested itself
in the form
of a mental escape a place that he could
go
to just cope if the theory doesn't sound
plausible to you
at all then i think this line from the
books movies
may influence the way that you think
about it in the deathly hallows
a confused harry asks a ghost dumbledore
if everything that's happening
is simply inside of his head to which
dumbledore replies
of course it is happening inside your
head harry
but why on earth should that mean that
it is not real
this is another powerful and
well-delivered quote from wise old
dumbledore
and whether this quote has underlying
meaning or not is up to reader
interpretation
i am of the impression that this line
certainly helps the argument
that the magical world the land of magic
was always a figment of harry's
imagination
our conception of what appears to be
reality is merely the product
of our own imperfect senses forming an
idea
around cognitive biases and filling in
gaps where it can
what dumbledore was getting at here is
that reality
is simply a mental construct formed in
an abstract manner
and that there is no black and white no
right and wrong
the pursuit of determining what reality
actually is
stems from insecurities surrounding our
own morality
but does satisfying our own insecurities
make it any more real one of the most
interesting aspects of this theory
is that it is quite difficult to refute
entirely
it depicts a world very much unlike the
magical world that we have become
accustomed to
and it's not something that i like to
imagine but
i can't argue it is plausible i hate to
imagine that
hagrid dumbledore the weasleys diagon
alley
and harry's kindred friendships with
hermione and ron are well
imaginary i kind of like and hate this
theory at the same time
it's mind-bending and forces you to look
at an already established narrative
in a completely different way but i also
don't like that it serves as an affront
to the magical world that i've loved
for so many years there's also an even
more twisted version of the same theory
a theory in which the chosen one harry
potter has completely and
utterly lost his mind the general theme
of the theory
is that for the entire time that harry
was under the impression that he was
attending hogwarts
he was actually at a mental hospital not
only that
but he isn't harry potter anymore he's
harry dursley
and he always was the son of his mean
uncle vernon
and aunt petunia everything that occurs
of the course of the books and films
were really just a highly over
exaggerated hallucinated version
of his life inside of this mental
hospital a fabrication
of the mentally ill harry dursley when
his 11th birthday came
and his abusive parents vernon and
petunia i shared her thinking about that
completely forgot it caused a mental
breakdown in harry
on this day harry snaps injuring his
imaginary brother
dudley at which point a wizard breaks
into their home
and takes him away to a wizarding school
which of course was
in reality just a mental institute this
theory
though disturbing and not something that
i want to accept for myself
makes the story of the harry potter
universe an almost
allegory for mental illness under abuse
stress and other circumstances the brain
can be pushed to do
extraordinary things what do you guys
think of this theory
personally even though it bears some
merit i'm of the opinion that harry
really did attend hogwarts let me know
in the comment section below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams
and forget to live
you